nicolas vidal directeur de la
publication putsch médias à ses côtés
henri sterdyniak économiste à l'ofce
membres des économistes atterrés bonsoir
à tous les deux merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france c'est un
avertissement que lancent les syndicats
au nouveau premier ministre en lice tard
dignac syndicats ont surpris les grandes
préoccupations des travailleurs
actuellement en emploi
un certain nombre de plans sociaux il ya
le problème des huit cent mille jeunes
qui vont arriver sur le marché du
travail s'attendait à ce qu'on parle de
l'emploi ils se retrouvent devant un
premier ministre qui leur parle des
retraites sujet qui n'est absolument pas
d'actualité actuellement on a un premier
ministre qui essaie d'utiliser le
déficit des retraites due à la crise
pour faire passer des mesures qui sont
absolument pas d'actualité
c'est pas quand il ya un grand problème
de l'emploi pour les jeunes qu'on va
dire qu'on va faire travailler les 62 64
ans donc naturellement les syndicats
nous ne pouvaient pas s'entendre avec ce
premier ministre après l'épidémie de
coronavirus reprendre le dossier
explosif de la réforme des retraites
c'est ce que les français attendent
selon vous nicolas vidal ah oui son
occupation les français d'avoir cette
réforme des retraites on l'a bien vu
pendant six mois
la réalité c'est que emmanuel macron
s'est débarrassé de leur fille pour le
sait tous mais il a nommé finalement ce
que j'appellerai un super directeur de
cabinet un emmanuel macron à jean castex
donc à ce côté vous savez c'est fanny un
peu plus tôt phobie cet accent un peu
gersois ce côté enraciné ce côté
populaire ce côté hommes des territoires
jean castex faut pas l'oublier c'est un
énarque que nos fonctionnaires mais ce
sera la cour des comptes
donc un côté d'ailleurs le boss du medef
a parlé du côté rugby man 2
de jean castex mais moi je pense que ce
n'est pas un pré ministre emmanuel nacro
il a nommé quelqu'un qui va pouvoir
mettre en place cette réforme des
retraites
c'est une fausse caution populaire jean
castex d'ailleurs je m'étonne toujours
qu'il n'y a toujours pas eu de discours
de politique générale jean castex alors
que les débats l'assemblée ont repris
leur gouvernement donc non je crois pas
que les français attendent vraiment la
réforme des retraites et donc mais il
est donc un texte et avec emmanuel
macron remède la table est couverte ou
c'est tout est prêt pour repartir
finalement dans un truc qui va être
intenable ramon à mon sens dans les
prochains jours et les prochaines
semaines alors il n'y a pas eu de
discours de politique générale mais tout
de même jean castets seul a précisé un
gouvernement de combat avec sait
davantage sur les territoires ça veut
dire quoi concrètement
henri sterdyniak vous l'économiste vous
lisez entre les lignes vous vous
attendez à quoi nous attend pas
n'attends pas grand-chose dire que c'est
un gouvernement de combat ça ne donne
pas beaucoup d'informations à tous les
gouvernements peuvent prétendre et de
gouvernement de combat en voit rarement
un premier ministre dire je suis là pour
ne rien faire le problème c'est quoi
faire naître une situation économique
difficile il faut absolument relancer il
faut fournir des emplois aux jeunes et
fournir des emplois aux jeunes ça doit
se faire en même temps avec la
transition écologique
donc il faut des emplois dans la
transition écologique dans la rénovation
des vosges mort dans les énergies
renouvelables dans les soins aux oraux
aux bébés rideau personnes âgées
donc il ya du boulot le risque c'est que
le gouvernement nous propose cette
érection et parler maintenant des
réformes des aides de la réforme des
retraites
c'est une provocation parce que on voit
pas qui va faire est ce qu'il va dire
aux retraités on diminue les retraites
est ce qu'il va dire aux 62 64 ans
rester au travail détriment de vos
enfants et vos petits enfants
c'est parfaitement ridicule un autre
part on a vu que la réforme des
retraites edge des tas de questions au
niveau des branches au niveau d'un
certain nombre de métiers pénibles
certains états certains également des
non salariés
on voit pas perdre encore un an à
disputer deux ça alors que on va avoir
un taux de chômage qui va dépasser les
12 %
nicolas vidal c'était maladroit de
revenir avec cette réforme des retraites
dans le même temps c'est le cas de le
dire on aurait reproché au gouvernement
de ne pas suivre sa ligne non parce que
la réforme des retraites il a réformé
mère d'emmanuel mac os x sont ils il
faut absolument qu'ils la passent et une
nouvelle fois je lui ai dit plusieurs
fois se voit trentaine si on la réforme
des retraites on peut pas la voir si on
ne voit pas ce qui se passe à bruxelles
l'union européenne
je rappelle toujours les grandes
orientations de politique économique qui
depuis 2018 demande un moment donné de
pouvoir mettre en place dans ces pays
les pays famille vous savez les pays
membres
la réforme des retraites donc emmanuel
map macron déjà il épouse la thèse de
bruxelles il dit ce néolibéralisme
totalement fou et donc il va la mettre
en place
donc ils changent pas donc on par le
gouvernement de combat mais en fait
c'était quoi avant un gouvernement de
plage je crois pas je crois que manuel
n'a point il a toujours ce même cap
mais avec jean castex il a une techno
administrateurs qui va continuer à
imposer sa et qui va mettre peut-être un
peu l'huile de coude dans les rouages
mais je crois que manuel da cruz c'est
vraiment sa réforme mer ils se moquent
finalement d'aller contre les français
donc après ce qui va se passer c'est qui
aura la rue probablement qui va
s'affronter à lui les français et on
verra bien
et toute façon pour finir là-dessus
stéphanie je pense que la seule chose
qui pourrait déverrouiller la situation
s'est un moment donné de poser la
question aux français sur un référendum
de la réforme des retraites
on ne dira oui manuel me prendre les
prêts à son programme mais on se rend
bien compte qu'aujourd'hui la rue a
parlé depuis un certain temps il ya eu
deux crises ducobu donc ça atténue et
bien entendu la révolte sociale
aujourd'hui on est plutôt dans
l'insurrection silencieuse et
municipales avec cette forte abstention
mais je crois qu'il pourra pas s'en
sortir emmanuel macron pour thème un art
où un référendum mais pas que lui
d'ailleurs un peu près tous la classe
politique depuis longtemps et je crois
que c'est la seule issue qui pourraient
s'offrir à lui mais il ne le fera jamais
vous savez ce sont des
ac aurait de dour et au référendum on
vous dit ça va finir dans la rue
effectivement la cgt a tout de suite
annoncé une heure après la réunion
une manifestation une grève le 17
septembre prochain henri sterdyniak ça
va être compliqué pour ce nouveau
gouvernement de réformer effectivement
si déjà il ya cette annonce à la grève
pour le 17 septembre on est reparti
comme avant
alors qu'on nous promettait des
changements n'est reparti pire qu'avant
vous avez vu que la cfdt a pris ses
distances vis-à-vis du gouvernement et
la cfdt a dit tout à fait clairement à
monsieur castex vous ne vous êtes pas du
tout dans dans le vôtre en poupe votre
histoire de réforme des retraites
c'est vraiment vraiment pas le moment
incident s'il ya des des plans sociaux
s'il ya un chômage des jeunes augmente
on va pas faire une réforme des
retraites avec ce que ça suppose de
d'augmentation de report de l'âge de la
retraite et ce cas ce que cela suppose
au niveau des négociations avec les
branches qui visiblement n'a pas autre
chose à faire il ya des entreprises qui
sont en difficulté
la question c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour ces entreprises et donc monsieur
castex il a loupé cette dire il a loupé
son rendez vous on attendait des
propositions précises sur la question
clé aujourd'hui qui est la question de
l'emploi et on peut rajouter comme la
fin de ce match est la question de la
revalorisation des emplois
le premier de corvée les gens qui se
sont révélés indispensable pendant la
crise et qui ont des salaires
complètement ridicule c'est une question
importante de remettre en cause
actuellement la distribution des revenus
en france
et la pression est l'impression que fait
celui-là la finance
il faut revaloriser les bas salaires et
une grande politique axée sur l'emploi
la question des retraites c'est c'est
pas c'est pas un sujet que pas
actuellement grandir les 30 milliards de
déficit des retraites en oubliant que
grosso modo il ya 200 milliards de
déficit de l'ensemble des finances
publiques et que de toute façon ça sera
on peut l'espérer résorber en partie
l'année prochaine alors effectivement
laurent berger le disait la priorité
c'est l'emploi
elle laisse avec un voilà qui accusait
le gouvernement de faire un chantage
avant pour l'allongement du temps de
travail la baisse des salaires
l'activité réduite pour le maintien en
emploi
je cite le gouvernement met en avant son
arsenal pour détruire massivement les
emplois nicolas vidal effectivement
c'est pas un bon signal on parle tous
les jours des plans de suppressions avec
les manifestations hier chez chez airbus
cherop ché ché obtient 20 sur
gouvernement ne prend pas la mesure à
huit mois je pose qui prend la mesure ce
qui sont moqués à une feuille de route
je voulais dit tout à l'heure il ya une
feuille route qui suit jean castex et
finalement il va fluidifier sa
nomination va fluidifier ce plan ce plan
néolibéral parce que pour moi c'est un
plan néolibéral ont pas au passage
d'ailleurs il faudrait peut-être que
jean castex occulte de la région ile de
france parce qu'ils n'arrivent plus à
payer la ratp laisse un tiers
ça serait peut-être bien d'avoir des
priorités aussi dans la vie mais et
d'ailleurs vous savez les la majorité
sur les plateaux de vos concurrents sont
toujours en train ça fait simone nous
explique la réforme des retraites
à première vue c'est très simple mais
personne n'en veut une majorité de
français ne veulent pas et puis après on
nous met toujours en phase ou savez on
pourra plus payer les cotisations pourra
plus qu'on pourra plus payer les
retraites en ce moment je rappellerai
quand même qu'il ya des enquêtes qui
sont sortis notamment des lignes cargo
at et de denis robert
en 2019 sur l'évasion fiscale qu'ils ont
estimés à 100 milliards vous avez aussi
une fraude sociale au cardinal qui a à
peu près de 30 milliards selon le
magistrat charles prat
donc si on veut aller chercher de
l'argent il ya si on va laisser de
combler certains déficits je pense qu'il
ya des mesures à prendre mais finalement
c'est une réforme idéologique la réforme
des retraites c'est qu'une réforme
idéologique dictées par bruxelles
désolé de le dire mais c'est comme ça on
a perdu nos souverainetés donc on va
chercher à bruxelles chez jambes pour
faire baisser les dépenses publiques
maximum peu importe l'emploi pas pareil
de localisation peu importe ça
d'ailleurs bruno le maire ne fait que
suggérer susurré conseiller
il ne faut jamais rien voilà où on en
est aujourd'hui henri sterdyniak
effectivement nicolas vidal met le doigt
sur un point important il faut quand
même trouver de l'argent effectivement
pour notamment relancer l'économie
financer toutes les dépenses publiques
qui ont été faites notamment pendant
cette crise ou est ce qu'on le trouve
jusqu'à présent on le trouve sans
problème
il ya la bce qui est fait pour ça le
problème c'est que avec la crise le
gouvernement a soutenu massivement les
ménages est aussi les entreprises
on s'est endettée massivement sur les
marchés financiers on a été aidé par la
bce les taux d'intérêt actuellement sont
très bas donc il n'y a pas de problème
pour trouver des sommes importantes
on sent des donc je le répète à des taux
extrêmement faible il faut pas mettre
l'accent sur les 30 milliards de déficit
des retraites en oubliant qu'il ya 200
milliards de déficit de l'ensemble du
des finances publiques qui est en partie
sa résorber l'année prochaine parce que
là l'activité vins automatiquement
reprendre lorsque le confinement pas
lorsque le confinement va baisser ce qui
est très important c'est qu'il faut pas
que durant dix ans la protection sociale
très le déficit qui a ôté qui a été
acquis si on peut dire en 2020 et sa
mort risque le risque que l'année
prochaine on va dire au chauffeur il
faut diminuer vos prestations parce que
l'unedic et des importantes on va dire
il faut diminuer les retraites parce que
les systèmes des retraites est en
déficit et ça c'est totalement
inacceptable
il faut que les déficits de la
protection sociale sera pris en charge
par l'état et que comme l'a dit mon
collègue il faut s'en prendre à
l'évasion fiscale à l'optimisation
fiscale et aussi aux inégalités de
revenus et à la financiarisation
merci nicolas vidal est enrayée
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france dans